Wow...
and I'm the not gay one.
T- oh wow look at our color scheme! It's very beautiful!
G and H- I know
H~ Guys we look so cute
I'm calling an Audible before we start this video.
That's a pun even though I don't know what that phrase actually means.
I've talked about Audible so many times before. Do you know about Audible?
You should know about Audible.
They have audio books. They have news. They have original audio shows.
They have comedy. They have so many different things for whatever kink you're into.
And Audible members now get more than ever...
you get three titles a month. You get one audio book and two "originable"...
Originable?
Two original Audible shows that you can't hear anywhere else.
Plus you get access to hundreds of fitness...
*struggles*
audio things that you can follow if you're into tha- this.
They also offer free and easy audio book exchanges
AND a library that you'll keep forever if you cancel...
So if you start listening with a 30 day trial
Your first audio book is free. Plus you get two free Audible originals.
Just visit
What a cryptic...
thing. Or text code
I love Audible. I literally signed my mom up for it and she's been listening to stuff like crazy
And literally yesterday I just finished Chelsea Handler's "Life Will Be the Death of Me"
Here are my receipts for the fact that I actually use Audible.
For the last week I've been listening to "Life Will Be the Death of Me" and I f *cymbal noise*ing love it...
and cannot recommend it enough.
You guys know that she was on my podcast a few weeks ago.
And it was like so wonderful and powerful for me
And the book is absolutely wonderful, but hearing her read the book
and she breaks down and she cries at moments and her voice shakes
And just hearing her emotion behind everything is so
powerful!
That's my recommendation for you guys.
Like I said, go to
or again text
Sign up for a 30 day trial, get your first audio book for free and
two Audible originals!
Now onto this f *cymbal noise*ing nonsense
Hi guys! My name is Grace Helbig
If you did not know now you know. Your life is different now!
I'm here with these three shenanigans
And would you like to personally introduce yourself or would you guys like to introduce each other?
H~ oooooo
T~This is Hannah
H~hi
T~She is
M~To your right
G~ OK! We have Hannah, Tyler, Mamrie. I'm taking your privileges away.
We wanted to shoot videos today for all of our channels.
So I thought it would be really fun because what's not
fun about digging up the past?
H~ Lots of things
G~ I kind of guesstimated that we all generally met around
the year 2011 into like 2012ish
T~ That was a very good year for pop music
M~ I was just gonna say Tyler would probably say that
T~Were you?
G~Oh my god
T~ Born This Way, Teenage Dream
M~ Oh wow
G~ Alright, I spent my morning deep diving on your
Twitter accounts from 2011 because I felt like
T, M, H~ Hmmm
G~ at the time those were the most reflective of our personalities since we didn't really have a handle on Instagram filters
at that moment.
M~ *whistles*
H~ Oh
SO
I wanted to play a game in which I present some
tweets from 2011
M~ mmhmm
G~ and then you guys would have to guess which one of you tweeted this
T~ This will be easy
M~I think so too
G~ Full disclosure, you guys were funny as fuck in 2011
M~ You know the political
climate was- the political climate was different
H~ The Obama era was an easy era to be funny in now there is no joy
M~ I was still bartending so my money wasn't dependent on how funny I was
H~ It's also- I am so curious about these- how these hashtags
are gonna look?
G~ Yep! I don't have any like rules
or whatever. You guys can buzz in if you think you know
H~ Oh ok
G~ Yeah, a little hand clap like that
T~ Oop, that's my heart
*laughing*
M~ Is there a name for this challenge?
G~I was gonna say
like Tweet Sheet, Throwback Thursday but Throwback Twitter
HTM~ Ooooo
H~Twitter Back
T~ Twitback Thursday
M~ Tweet Fighter
H~ You can't take twat back!
M~ That's what she said
G~ Here we go, first tweet.
M~ Hannah
H~ *defeated* Hannah
G~ Hannah, what's your answer?
H~ Hannah
G~ You're correct
H~ Hashtag always
Me!
T~ Is it? Was it?
H~ Is it Tyler?
G~ Tyler what's your answer?
T~ Is it me?
G~ Yes it is
T~ That's a good tweet. I would tweet it today.
M~ Did I tell you? I was riding around in my car the other day and I thought
"Girls just wanna have funyuns" and I was like that's funny. I should check and see if anyone has tweeted it.
I googled it. ME! 7 years ago!
T~ You had.
M~ Boop! Hannah
T~ Boom! Me
G~ It's Tyler
M~ AHHHH
T~ Because...
I held onto my knock off razor
flip phone for as long as I humanly could
H~ And if it had been me I might have done hashtag Tweet yourself
M~ True
M~ Right now it's very bad to
tweet about R. Kelly
but I loved "Trapped in the Closet" at the time
H~ Ok
M~ But it wouldn't be me
That's a boring ass tweet
M~ I think it's Tyler
G~ It's Tyler Oakley
*indistinguishable laughter*
G~ "It wouldn't be me. That's a boring ass tweet"
M~ The man loves his math
T~ Well there were a lot of chapters
M~ There were
H~ 54?!?
T~ Oh, Mamrie
H~ I gonna say Mamrie
H~ 100%
T~ I don't even get the tweet
M~ No diggity, no doubt
M~ If it has to do with early 90s R&B
T~ Unless it's Bone Thugs cause that's very my lane
M~ Me
H~ I think that's Mamrie
M~ I get itchy
G~ Collectively saying Mamrie?
H~ Or Tyler?
T~ I don't think it's me
M~ I think me
H~ I think it's Mamrie
T~ Is it me?!?
G~ I'm just asking. Now this has become a game of collective thought
T~ I think it's Mamrie
G~ It is Mamrie Hart
H~ I get itchy
M~I get itchy
T~ME! No? I've seen both episodes
H~ I had never seen either
M~ I have never seen scabs
H~ So I'm gonna say...I'm gonna say it's Tyler
G~ It is Tyler Oakley
M~ YES
H~ You are so good at this!
T~ Yeah
H~ Oh, I think that's me
M~ Hannah
M~ It's probably Hannah
T~ What does that mean?!?
G~ That is Hannah Hart
T~ Endless tears? What was that?
M~ Are you ok?
H~ I don't wanna talk about it
G~ She couldn't hashtag
H~ I couldn't hashtag hashtag
H~ How do you hashtag hashtag?
M~ Hashtag the word hashtag
H~ Yeah *mumbles*
M~ I don't know if the second half of that tweet sounds like me
T~ UH we've never had blackberries
H~ Yeah
M~ You didn't
T & H~ NO
M~ Losers
T~ Never in our lives
M~ I also said classic a lot
*everyone saying classic*
G~ You say, "ok bye" in like every-
G~ I thought this was
a joke because Tyler and Hannah have tweets about them
like waiting for their iPhones to get in the mail and then
and then here's about Blackberry and I was like, "Is this for real?"
H~ Oh my God, that's so cute
H~ That's Tyler
T~ That's still me
I have a lot of Tweets that are "My hobbies include..."
M~ I love we all know our formats. Hannah's are sad hashtags
H~ Imma say me
T~ You would find the joy in that
M~ Yeah Yeah
M~ I don't see myself hash tagging small miracles
H~ Hash-tagging small miracles?
G~ Oh wait wait wait. Sorry, hashtag "small_miracles"
M~ Definitely Hannah
T~ Definitely Hannah
H~ Nobody uses the underscore!
How do you even read them all together?
T~ Oh no
M~ Oh my God
G~ Here we go. "David Archuleta is-"
T~ Me
G~ 43 people liked this tweet in December of 2011
H~ Damn!
M~ Good job!
T~ We call that viral
M~ Hannah
H~ It's me, definitely, 100%
G~ Do you wanna guess the hashtag on this tweet?
H~ Oh no!
M~ Hashtag "impeach this"
H~ Ooo, I like that
M~ Hashtag "Peachy mean"
H~ Peach it to the choir
G~ No it's just hashtag "conundrums"
M~ Why?
M~ Damn Africa?
T~ Because it's a Mean Girls quote. It must be me.
M~ Oh, yeah
H~ Definitely Tyler
T~ I think maybe me.
H~ I think you
H~ It sounds like you
T~ Why did I come for her, if it was me?
H~ I know
T~ Why was I angry at Sinéad?
G~ And that is a Tyler Oakley quote
T~ I really had things to say. No longer.
M~They're all said
T~ They're all said
H~ They're all said
M~ Me
H~ Oh wow
T~ Me me me me
M~ That's Tyler
T~Desperate for a brand deal. Desperate for free food.
M~Yeah
M~That'd be me!
H~Ayy!
G~You even put the zing on the end of it! You put zing!
T~Ew!
T~This is fun.
H~I really have enjoyed this a lot.
G~You guys were extremely funny back then, so it's good to see that nothing has changed.
T~Thank you.
T~Mmm.
M~Aww.
H~Thank you for your [service?]
G~You guys are all winners. This is not a well-thought out game. It's just a trip down memory lane.
M~I love it.
H~I love it! I love that we get to spend *cries* time together.
G~Oh, god.
M~#feelings #--
H~Oh my god!
G~#_feelings
M~#conundrum
G~If you guys don't know this by the obvious fact that this is what we're doing,
we're making videos on all of their channels. All links will be in the description box below.
Go check it all out!
Um, I mean, I have still yet to fully understand what we're doing on all of the channels so...
it'll be a surprise for both of us and don't forget to subscribe to this channel.
I make videos--
and, um, all the other--
M~period.
G~Um, other than that, I don't know.
G~Look, I'm not saying I need to start working out, I'm simply saying that I just pulled a muscle while tightening my bra strap.
M~That'd be me
H~Ooo
T~Wasn't me.
H~Wasn't Tyler, and I only wear sports bras. Mamrie Hart.
M~And I do a lot of, "I'm not saying..."
H~Yeah
T~Zing!
H~Classic zinger of a Mamrie tweet.
G~Zing! That one, you dropped the zing at the end.